so if you've been plugged in at all over
the last few days you've clearly heard
about the United Airlines story of what
happened of this man of a dr. David
Dowell being drugged off of a flight
that he did not volunteer to dis board
accordingly according to all the reports
United overbooked this was their fault
they sought volunteers they offered up
to eight hundred dollars for someone to
leave when no one volunteered Pat they
randomly selected for people the doctor
David Dowell he was one of them he let
them know that he couldn't I get off the
plane because he had patients to tend to
and this is actually what happened to
him when he refused to get off the plane
used to be there he hit the face
let me go home I have to go home I have
to go home I never look like clearly
this human Bobby let me go Kimmy that's
hear me thank you me that came Islam so
I'm to make a bad situation worse well
let's start here United has had a
horrible last month in public relations
and it's horrible because of their own
doing last I believe two weeks ago they
had an entire scandal on social media as
a result of them banning a young woman
from boarding a plane because she had on
leggings it wasn't just that they banned
her it was the response afterwards that
made it worse and this is very similar
to what's going on with this story Pat
it was the CEOs response that made this
worse at first I would just say that
this over boarding procedure has to go
right it's like airlines have a lot of
leeway to do whatever they want given
the sensitivity around air travel but if
you're if you pay for a seat you should
be guaranteed that seat there's right
taking it away right especially once you
board so United has clear policies
outline that stipulates that they have
the right to prevent you from boarding
in the case of overbooking but this guy
was already on the plane yeah and and
there's really nothing in their
guidelines that say that they can
forcibly remove you once you've already
boarded and there's definitely nothing
in the guidelines that said that you're
going to get off the plane with a
bloodied face right absolutely but also
if you're asked to get off the plane you
should probably get off the plane but
you know if this guy's saying he's a
doctor he has to get back home to do
surgeries or whatever not you know I
think another passenger should volunteer
at that point I'd like to think that if
I was on that plane I realized the
doctor absolutely has to be on this
flight that I would volunteer right and
well in and it goes even further than
that so united airlines they had the
ability to go up to thirteen hundred
dollars to entice someone to be board
the plane they didn't do that they
stopped at eight hundred dollars and
instead of going all the way they
resorted to getting the police involved
Chicago police at their finest getting
involved and bloodying up this passenger
so here they are with quote unquote free
market solutions that they try to use to
fix this but as soon as they didn't go
to
the highest amount instead of doing that
they resorted to brute force quite
literally right this is the libertarian
method I guess you'd say exactly a free
market run thing exactly so when the
free market fails they go to
authoritarianism clear as day alright so
this the situation was compounded made
even worse by the CEOs lackluster
response he said this is Oscar muñoz he
said this is an upsetting event to all
of us here United I apologize for having
to re accommodate these customers our
team is moving with a sense of urgency
to work with the authorities and conduct
our own detail review of what happened
we are also reaching out to this
passenger to talk directly to him to
further address and resolve the
situation Pat that's not how you address
a situation that all of the world is
looking at at this point and then he
reached out to the people within his own
staff write and write some mo there
right so he reached out so that was his
public the public response was pathetic
but then his internal response was even
worse this is what he said internally he
said our employees follow the
established procedures for dealing with
situations like this while I deeply
regret the situation arose I also
emphatically stand behind all of you and
I want to commend you for going for
continued to go above and beyond to
ensure we fly right this is this is you
know he actually went on to say that
that the that basically this guy was
belligerent that this was you know
partly his fault and I get that airlines
are used and our custom to being able to
tell people to get off their flights but
in a situation like this with a video
that has now been seen by tens of
millions of people probably 50 million
people have seen this you do not respond
like this this is making your own
disaster even worse and that response
has all the hallmarks of one of those
non apologies and please tell me that
what the hell is Rhea comma date you
don't react on date people you didn't
react AMA date this guy you know hug him
off the plane like and also it's
hilarious that they said that he refused
to volunteer I'm sorry I think you
missed one of the core hallmarks of
volunteerism is he willingly does this
and instead of willingly doing this they
said that he refused to volunteer
nevermind the fact that he was a doctor
that he had to get to his page
but the language and this casual
dismissal of the significance really is
what undermined them I think they lost
250 million dollars in stock share on
yes and stock value on yesterday alone
so they didn't want to go up to thirteen
hundred and fifty dollars but they you
know lost 250 million dollars of value
last but not least is the final apology
that came from the CEO he finally got
wind of what was going on he said the
truly horrific event that occurred on
this fight has elicited many responses
from all of us outrage anger
disappointment I share all those
sentiments and above all my deepest
apologies for what happened like you I
continue to be disturbed by what
happened on this flight and I deeply
apologize to cuss to the customer
forcibly removed and to all the
customers aboard no one should ever be
mistreated in this way this is when he
finally Pat realized that he screwed up
right once the videos have gotten tens
of millions of views once his stock
price started falling probably once his
own job got into jeopardy now here's the
B side of the story that really bothers
me as a commentator pundit whatever the
heck you want to call me it's the
media's response and have a couple
examples of here of what the media does
what journalists so-called journalists
do whenever this type of event happens
and by this type of event I mean anytime
someone is accosted by the police you
get someone in media who thinks it's a
good idea to dig up the past of the
victim in order to attack their
character and here's the first example
on your screen from morgan watkins of
the chicago job I'm sorry
courier-journal calm she elicited she
requested online for someone to put her
in touch with this gentleman so that she
can get his side of the story once she
got the name of the doctor and did a
public record search this is a story
headline that she wrote Pat she said
David Dowell passenger removed from the
united flight a doctor with a troubled
past this was picked up on the on the
right hand side by the New York Post and
they reported doctor dragged off the
flight was convicted of trading drugs
for sex let's talk about that for a
second this has absolutely nothing to do
we
what happened on that plane so as a
journalist why put this into the
conversation if for no other reason than
to try to find an angle to find
something to sensationalize and to drive
clicks it's like after when Trayvon
Martin was shot and killed there was
media reports that he had marijuana in
his system where when Michael Brown was
shot by a police officer it came out
that he robbed the convenience store as
we know now he had a prior agreement
with that to me that gory but in either
case it's completely irrelevant to what
happened exactly because no one involved
in the situation George Zimmerman did
not know the Trayvon Martin had been
smoking weed and my god what's look
everybody you know who doesn't smoke
weed at this point right at least in
Massachusetts then you have with Michael
Brown Darren Wilson did not know about
this about this alleged strong-arm
robbery that turned out not to be a
strong armed robbery but the media
inserts it into the conversation almost
like a PR firm right think about it like
this if United had hired a PR firm to do
this on their behalf United might be in
trouble of going out of business because
it's that discussing of a move but
instead of United having to do this
media has done it voluntarily for them
that's true but they are also playing
the video over and over again on all of
the major corporate outlets there so it
is not like they're completely in
united's pocket well no no so it's not
to suggest that they're in the United
pocket but it is it suggests that some
journalists and actually we have another
example here two more examples so this
is the courier journals actual headline
and the sharing of the tweet David
Dowell jae'nt they show I'm sorry they
showed a picture of his home in
Elizabethtown saying that he has a
trouble pass and then Lisa Fletcher from
ABC 7 News she bragged about this my
desk is covered with court and legal
documents in response to the trouble
pass of the doctor pulled off United our
report at four o'clock now online she
ended up deleting that tweet because
everyone let them know that this is not
the job of journalists to undermine and
to attack the character of people who
have been victimized especially when
that information has absolutely nothing
to do with the incident that transpired
and unless we hold journalists and the
media
countable they will continue to do these
types of things